hallo mein name ist luca und mein handy
gut geklaut ich war vom letzten freitag
bis gestern bis mittwoch in wien dass es
in österreich das ist eine sehr schöne
stadt das wetter war aber hart scheiße
ich war dort weil am samstag einen fan
treffen war hier mal ein paar
ausschnitte
dernau es gibt keine ausschnitte der
mein handy weg und am dienstag war noch
sonne preisverleihung für einen
österreichischen -influenza dingsda dann
kumpel was gefilmt und zwar zeige ich
euch mal wie ich mich da auf der bühne
verhalten habe man merkt ich kann so was
ich bin auf jeden fall gerade ihr seht
schon wieder an hintergrund ich bin zu
hause bei meinen eltern weil ich keine
uni habe irgendwie ich weiß das ist halt
studentenleben dicker das so entspannt
ich sag euch mal wie das alles dazu
gekommen ist dass ich mein handy
verloren habe ich mache ein bisschen so
dann haben wir dramatik wegen rantzow
oder auch nicht ich bin am freitag nach
wien geflogen und waren halt erstmal
waren relativ spät abends erst da direkt
ins hotelzimmer gepennt und am samstag
den ganzen tag fantreffen irgendwie
ihren fan treffen sind wir angekommen um
9 uhr dann hatte ich irgendwie autogramm
slots von 10 bis 12 und 14 bis 16 und
das war's so ihre alter da haben leute
weiter habe gelernt mir wurden auch
unglaublich viele sachen geschenkt ich
bin nachher mit zwei so riesigen mosaik
nehmen wir ja die bahn nicht so groß die
waren eher die wahren lockt wie so
locker oder doch bereit davon habe ich
zwei stück bekommen und das war alter
das ist da sind so viele sachen drin wir
wurden ukulelen geschenke wurden kekse
geschenk pizzen sowas von viele
telefonnummern halter als das habt ihr
mir alles gebastelt und mir wird dann
auch so gesagt so dass das leute dann
einfach klar irgendwie zwei monate an
summen alpaka stofftier was mir
geschenkt wurde namens carl genäht haben
danke die ganze sache befinden sich der
für den berlin die werden mir zugesandt
und irgendwie in zwei drei vier wochen
werde ich das nochmal alles auspacken
vielleicht in einem facebook live stream
oder auf instagram einfach mal alles
abfotografieren oder ich glaub ich
mach's bei snap chat ich kann euch
wirklich nur empfehlen mit west zu
folgen ich heiße dort laser luca ich
falls ich bekomme dafür nichts das sage
ich werdet ich mache da keine product
placement bekomme aber auch kein geld
für aber wenn ein video mal ich komme
weil ich noch im stau stehe oder wenn's
mir scheißegal wenn
die weg ist oder so ihre erfahrung ist
nur oder am pc ich sag mal am
schnellsten bei snap chat weil ich bei
twitter postete echt nicht so häufig
irgendwie sowas bei facebook gar nicht
weil instagram kommen auch er so viel
damit blöden unter trainer beim
entscheid kommt wirklich immer so wenn
ihr das ist ein daily blog von mir aber
darum sollte ich gehe ihr habt schon im
titel gelesen mein handy das mit luca
wie ist das passiert ist es so passiert
wir waren auf jeden fall vom fällen
treffen wieder weg nachdem noch vor dem
bus hat tausende leute standen und alles
war in einem hotelzimmer haben uns
frisch gemacht bisschen noch gepennt und
dann meine bei der aftershow party wird
waren bei der after show wirklich so von
11 bis halb fünf am nächsten tag will
natürlich hackl strammen wir haben echt
viel alkohol konsumiert weil wirklich
der tag hat einen so fertig gemacht und
sondern wir wollten das einfach feiern
weil das ganze event für ultra geil und
wir haben bisher noch keine großartig
negativen rückmeldungen bekommen
natürlich meinen viele so yoga macht
stunden gewartet und haben kein
autogramm bekommen aber freude da kann
ich nichts für also wenn das event um 10
uhr los geht meines lotte zum
autogrammeschreiben könnt ihr natürlich
nicht um 10 uhr da sein weil da sind
dann natürlich schon schlangen aber das
tut mir leid falls sie mal was nicht
bekommen aber ich bin ja auch noch bei
den video days und so anzutreffen
jedenfalls wenn ich dann am nächsten tag
im hotelzimmer aufgemacht um 11 uhr
guckt so neben mich fast so mich rum
statt eine wasserflasche um den kopf
gegen schrank und mein kopf tut so weh
und irgendwann fragt man sich natürlich
auch solo es eigentlich mein handy cook
so rumpf in das so nicht guckst du auf
meinem laptop klicks auf die website
mein iphone suchen guckt wo zuletzt
online 1 uhr 30 in gegenden im klub
alles klar habe ich nach freundin so
gesagt so jäger guck mal war meine
letzte snap the story gepostet wurde ja
das war irgend sowas getrunken hast um
halb vier war dass ich dann natürlich
erstmal allen möglichen leuten
geschrieben egal was geht mich nur so
antwortet die junge du lebst man was so
voll scheiße es haben aber einige wohl
was verloren als ich auch von anderen
irgendwie dass sie irgendwie auch eine
ec karte verloren haben oder so war auch
stark ist war auf ihrem acker abend mein
handy bis halt weg hab ich halt erstmal
hin und her telefoniert um irgendwie das
hinzukriegen dass derjenige der das
findet nicht mein handy reingeht zum
glück beim 10.000 aber auf jeden fall
das handy direkt über diese apple app da
sperren lassen und nachrichten aufgebaut
hat das land seiner findet kann er sich
dann bei einer telefonnummer melden und
so aber hat keiner gefunden und zur
polizei gegangen anzeige erstatte ich
hatte jetzt natürlich keinen bock darauf
zu warten dass ich vielleicht das handy
immer mal wieder finden im jahr deswegen
hab mir die kehle ist kein placement
also ich bekomme kein geld für das jetzt
sagen und ich hab das handy auch nicht
umsonst bekommen aber ich habe mir
einfach absetzen ich hab mir neu gekauft
ich weiß nicht wieso das weiße witzig
war auch ich habe dann mit leuten von
meinem netzwerk studio 1 70 geschrieben
und meine ganze jahr wisst ihr noch was
abgehen im club ich auch ein bisschen
filmriss hat sondern kommen zu null so
die antwort ja luca wir haben hier
dieses bild von dir gefunden das ist ja
also ich dass das beschreibt eigentlich
ein abend ganz gut dann war halt mein
handy weg und dann war ich den
kompletten sonntag quasi nur seine
ausnüchtern bisschen was essen und so am
montag dienstag waren erhalten in der
stadt und so immer und am dienstagabend
war dann halt das game changer event wo
es darum ging dass eine österreichische
website preis bekommt ihr fehlt darum
dass youtuber unter anderem leute sind
die das ganze irgendwie bewegen und
irgendwie einfluss haben auf die jugend
barbara keine ahnung also lasst mich
damit in ruhe jeden fall ist es ist war
halt in wien und es ist denn dass es in
öster
das ganze ist ein österreichischer preis
von dem österreichischen fernsehsender
und dann gehe ich auf die bühne mit drei
anderen österreichischen youtuber nass
waren k s creek jana und michael buhre
und ich stehe dann so als einziger
deutscher und denke mir nur so jung
das ist genauso wie wenn sie noch einmal
die deutsche bundesliga gewinnen würde
das geht einfach nicht mein stellt euch
vor ihr macht bei den tendern wettkampf
mit parcours oder so und da tritt man
selber als und gegen drei andere hunde
an und dann auf einmal gewinde katze ja
das hat keinen sinn ergeben aber dass
das hat das da hat auch keinen sinn
ergibt das ganze bild rako des gartner
after show ich habe wieder was getrunken
an dieser stelle möchte ich euch mal
fragen kennt ihr jonas youth on tv der
war auch auf der after show der hatte
dann gedacht mir einfach mal wein über
die haare zu schützen das war auf jeden
fall auch ultra entspannen jonas nochmal
hält dann kann ich an dieser stelle ja
und das war es für sie schon als mein
handy war halt weg deswegen war ich vier
tage nicht richtig aktiv bei twitter
youtube instagram snapshot einstecken da
sonst mal täglich so viel und jetzt auf
einmal gar nichts mehr es tut mir sehr
leid dabei jetzt kommt wieder was ich
wollte euch das ganze nur sagen wenn ihr
das video gerade steht ist
wahrscheinlich donnerstagnachmittag
früher abend das video sollte eigentlich
gestern schon kommen die sache ist nur
wegen dem flug streit gestern bin ich
acht stunden am flughafen gewesen aber
auch mein thema gewalt oder sechs
stunden oder 40 stunden dann habe ich
mir gedacht ich nehme am flughafen video
auch aber hey du findest am flughafen
keine stelle wo irgendwie mal nicht alle
zwei sekunden durchsage kommt und diana
durchs bild läuft so sah das dann aus
hat sich das video gedreht habe falls
ihr euch fragt was das da ist das ist
ja ich habe das video auf einer
behindertentoilette gedreht ja sonst
würde ich sagen ich wollte einfach mal
darüber quatschen wieso ich offline war
wie das ganze passiert ist und ich hatte
kein video freute deswegen ja das war
sensorik gefallen hat würde ich mich
über eine bewertung freuen und falls die
ideen habt eventuell für nächste videos
oder so real life mäßig über was ich
machen soll ich mal meine schuhe sehen
ich habe 15 farben die sagen die alle
scheiße oder was wollt ihr sehen alter
keine ahnung ich kann dir auch eine
fernbedienung zeiten irgendwie eine
tasche die ich ja auch noch irgendwie
hab also keine ahnung wenn ich irgendwas
heute oder fragen beantworten oder ciao